[Music]
hello and welcome to staying awake i
have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams hello and
oscar isaac i have been waiting a long
time to interview you my friend and i
have three words for you
the skirt's working
i love it i agree
such a good luck um i i've always
admired watching you on screen because i
know that you love taking roles and
experiences that are just so outside of
your own
and i was reading that you said in an
interview that moon knight is the first
legitimate character study in marvel
since iron man so i was wondering why is
that and what about this character sort
of granted you that experience
well yeah well thank you for for that um
i
yeah i guess i guess
what i mean by that is that it
you know it it really the whole story is
from the point of view of the character
um and it's introducing a whole new uh
character and and how he feels and what
he's going through and the entire series
is a is a outward expression of his
internal struggle with mental health in
particular um and his his revelation and
then healing from
abuse and trauma so
all of those aspects
done inside of a marvel superhero show
just seemed like such a unique and crazy
experience
your range is like it's unbelievable
like what you i hope you were just so
proud of yourself and it's really fun as
a fan
for all of us to watch you close that
gap you know of things that feel so
outside of yourself i mean that's the
idea i mean that's that's like really
really well
put because i think that is for me what
the fun of acting is you know it's like
like any skill you know you you the
better you get at it the more you want
to challenge yourself and do something
that's harder and the magic for me is
like finding a character that feels like
it has nothing to do with your personal
experience and
you know the magic is like how do you
find that truth and do it and like
that's what makes i think
the magic is like you don't feel alone
like it's like you people feel seen
because it's like how did you know you
know and that's an amazing thing yeah
and that there's so much inside of us
that we didn't even know which speaking
to that point you know one of your every
woman
it's all in me
[Laughter]
to that point oscar you know you i was
reading that you specifically wanted to
give steve a british accent to sort of
you know to be able to differentiate a
little bit easier i wanted to ask you
why british
and who did you draw what voice did you
draw upon for that did you listen to
tapes like who are you sort of emulating
uh it actually wasn't to differentiate
uh because i it was just like who is
stephen it it was set when i got that
first episode it was set in london but
he wasn't he was written as american so
i said
why is this set in london and they just
said well we have too many heroes in new
york we have too many new york stories
we just wanted to change it up so we
just made him an ex-pat and i was like
all right but there seemed like there
was an opportunity
to do something different for me you
know like that was part of it so so what
would keep me interested is like well
what if we made him english what if we
made him a londoner you know and then i
looked at like uh you know that you know
where did because i still wanted it's
very important he's still jewish and
he's but he's english and you know i
listened to russell kane who's a
comedian that you know his biography
kind of fits that and you know comes
from like a suburb out of london called
enfield so there was that i listened to
people from there i thought about carl
pilkington i don't know if you know what
that is he's like an idiot abroad he's
like part of ricky gervais oh that
show's so good
yeah yeah so he's more like more north
but it was more about his like his sense
of humor where he you can't tell if he
knows he's being funny you know
so it was like i i drew a little bit
from that a little bit from russell
brand you know
um and just kind of found this this
character god it's so good and it's so
funny too like i love that british humor
so so good and it's funny that you said
londoner they just wanted to like make
him from london we got to get a we got
to get a dominican or guatemalan avenger
in here at some point
i mean i don't want to spoil anything
but you know watch the whole series you
know you see there might be some
surprises in there okay so the other
thing is we've got a lot of english guys
coming over to you know coming over to
be like doing new york accents i felt
like it was time to repay the favor a
little bit totally and another way that
moon knight's different too is the
brutality oscar like i feel like when
avengers fight bad guys it's not as
violent so i wanted to ask you about the
physicality of this character and did
you channel energy from any of your
other characters because william tell in
the card counter kind of comes to mind
when you're watching it right no there
are it's funny there are some
similarities there because he's also a
military guy and someone that's clearly
dealing with a lot of rage issues uh but
um but no that that definitely was a cue
from the comic i mean that's part of him
he's incredibly brutal and and and for
me again it was it was tying that to the
emotional trauma that happened which is
you know and what kanchu represents
which is
that's his vengeance and his rage
against the people that did him wrong
you know
and and that that comes out as
punishment uh to others
uh and so that was it was important that
there is a brutality to his physicality
[Music]
ethan thank you so much for doing this
it means so much to me i've always
wanted to interview you congratulations
on moon night uh i know you've probably
been asked this a bunch today but you
know i read that you met oscar isaac in
a coffee shop you guys live in the same
neighborhood he walked in
asked you to be a part of this show i
was curious as to what he said to you
that made you go yeah
i want to do this
you know what it was
is it was really kind of the passion in
his eyes and the
the kind of fire you felt about how much
he wanted to play his character
and i've learned over time you know that
when
somebody has that
somebody talented has a fire in them to
do something it generally turns out
pretty interesting even if it doesn't
isn't successful or something
it'll definitely be a journey worth
taking
and i've been
watching these marvel movies for years
now and wondering what it would be like
to be in them
and i realized that
oscar and i have the same kind of
vocabulary about
movies and acting and and i knew we
would be good partners i just sensed it
so i thought oh if i'm ever going to do
this
you know if i'm ever going to jump into
this sandbox now's the time this is the
moment to do it so i felt
kind of clear right off the bat isn't it
cool when the stars align like that it's
so cool do you what do you remember
about that day like do you remember what
he was wearing
well you know the thing about the
pandemic is everybody's got a mask on
and i remember how hard it was to have
the conversation in a mask and i
remember
my daughter was there
and
[Music]
she's really cool and really smart and i
walked away
from the conversation with oscar with
her and i was like what do you think
about that and she was like you should
do that
yeah and so you know you remember the
strangest details i remember being cold
and wishing i didn't have a mask on yeah
it is exciting when you're around
someone that's just so excited to work
and like as much as you want to so so
you meet you do the show you've now done
the show the world's about to see it
what was it like working with oscar then
was it was it everything you thought you
know were you great partners and what do
you love about him as an actor
well
there's a lot of questions in one i
think that
definitely
carried a a giant workload i mean he's
playing multiple
characters inside one person
he's
we had to jump off
really without a finished script with
the whole thing so we would spend every
we would work all week
then we would spend we'd meet for brunch
every sunday to go over the up and
coming work
and read through the whole scripts to
try to keep making sure
we were all on the same page making the
same show because it's
the show's confusing because you have a
hero who has a multiple personality
disorder so you're seeing it from
multiple points of view and it was
difficult to track and figure out wait
okay so that's his point of view but
what's reality and what
and so coming up with may's character
and how that can all integrate well and
giving the directors confidence and it
was a tremendous amount of work plus he
had to learn all these
fight scenes and
and work on different accents and
different voices and different body
postures for the characters so it was a
big jump off the
high dive you know i mean he was really
taking a dare doing this and
he just showed up every day and he never
gave himself permission to fail you know
no matter what went wrong or whatever it
was well how are we gonna
succeed despite that you know
um
and i like people like that it was a
massive workload he plays several
personas for your character and for you
personally ethan which one did you like
playing off of the most
the one i like the most is the one i
have to keep the most secret oh come on
can you okay so can you tell me a little
bit about it without saying it um
yeah
it
what was fun
for me
as
as a student of acting and a lover of it
and stuff is to watch how hard it was
for him at the beginning and how easy it
was for him at the end
you know he really he really got so
comfortable and so fluent
in the vocabulary of these characters
and he could go from one voice to the
other voice and back again
in the course of a scene and at first he
couldn't even dream of doing such a
thing
um
and
for me
when you have
normally the the villain is the one
who's insane right that's usually at a
he escaped from a mental institution and
we have a hero who's suffering from
mental illness so it made it i had to
play a different position than you
normally have to as a as a villain you
know i mean i had to try to balance the
show out so i had to come up with
somebody who was
both malevolent but incredibly sane
and even to try to give the show ballast
you know um
you can't have the joker come in and
appear when you're heroes i mean it was
just like it'd just be cake on cake you
know so
um
i don't know
i love
science fiction and i love good
storytelling and so the joy for me
was
trying to help
make
this dynamic
story make sense and be entertaining
yeah well you were so brave in your
subtlety because you're right that is
like a fine line to be a villain but
also be the same one like you don't
think about that but the way you just
said it i was reading that you pulled
from carl young and david koresh and i
was wondering what you pulled from each
from each of those things to bring into
your take on arthur herrera
well i started as oscar talked more and
more about did which is dissociative
identity disorder which is what his
character is suffering from
the murat was he was talking about how
dreams are a big part of it and symbols
are a big part of how they create their
personalities and i
and
i thought the best counterpoint to a
patient would be a doctor
you know like what if what if it felt
more like the villain was like a doctor
so i started thinking about carl jung
and then i also felt like well
we're dealing with all this mythology
and you should also be kind of a priest
a priest doctor so like
the dalai lama meets carl young gone bad
you know
so i just put all those ideas in a
blender and so i wanted him to look like
a monk and sound like a doctor you know
always because my character is trying to
rid the world of pain wasn't that what
doctors do right yeah just the trouble
is if you don't have any pain it means
you're not alive
um
to live is to hurt right so
um
i don't know but those are where the
inspirations came from
some of the suit
some in the soup what are you saying the
suit the suit and keep this safe
[Music]
may congratulations on moon night what a
wild ride man to go from like a comedy
drama like romney to like this
massive mcu oscar isaac ethan hawk like
ah tell me everything like what what was
that like going from that to that
i didn't i i was not prepared like i
didn't know what i was getting myself
into i was just like yeah i'll do it
i'll do it i'm ready and then when i got
there i was so intimidated just working
with like i grew up loving ethan in in
so many movies and i had to act cool
about it right
um
but
slowly i was like okay these guys i mean
and because i was intimidated i saw how
i didn't really know it's been awkward
i'm really good at being awkward but
then um after a while i realized the
more vulnerable i can be in sharing
where i felt stuck or where something
was new the the more i allowed them to
help me and they were so
they really empowered me wherever and
oscar like taught me so much i would
watch him i'd be like how do you do
green screen and i just like watch how
he did it and i feel like i moved
through this like the work like that by
just kind of studying him
and seeing how free and how he just
commits and it's like even if even if
you throw out a bad idea or even if what
you do isn't good
there's no shame in going all out like
for them you know whereas i'm like oh i
don't want to commit and go all out to
hear like may that was like a lot don't
do that you know but i realized that's
that's where the magic is where you just
throw yourself in and if they're like
okay like reel it in or try this or oh
you inspired us for something else
that's the collaboration
and um
yeah i'd say like more than anything
this was a learning process for me which
was so fun
wow well you are fantastic in it and i
mean yes like it is so vulnerable right
to just go all out and it's funny why is
it so scary for all of us as humans to
just like try things it's so silly what
did you learn
because you mentioned you learned a lot
from oscar and it feels like you know it
was like a student sort of teacher
relationship in a way did you
what did you learn from him just by
watching him and then did he say
anything to you because you said that
they empowered you in a lot of ways is
there something that he said to you that
stuck with you
uh i feel like him and ethan were able
to see
that it wasn't always easy especially in
the beginning we had like these
development uh days where we'd spend six
hours
on the weekend whenever we found a day
where we weren't all filming just to
kind of go over an episode
and they could tell i think that it was
a little hard for me to use my voice
about certain
topics every you know like
how i felt she should i was in a room
full of men you know i had muhammad
diab's wife there but yeah there was a
part of me that was like i just don't
want to mess up i'm just going to like
be right here but they'd like pull out
my opinion and if something didn't feel
right they'd give me that space to
really explain and they'd really want to
work with it they never got brushed over
which which i appreciate because it
could have gotten gone the other way and
i definitely had moments on set where
i just turned to oscar and be like i
don't know
how to do this moment right now like
it's it's weird the circumstance is
weird i come from a show where things
are
just hyper real and realistic and
natural to this
and he would help ground it for me and
talk me through the moment and that was
great direction and so i always thank
him i'm like
you're you're playing like the most
intense role and you still manage to
find time to be generous well may good
for you though i mean you are a
spectacular in this it's so fun watching
you in it and and it's fun watching you
and oscar in the same scenes together
was that
because obviously he plays you know
different personas was that really
confusing and did you have a favorite
persona that you'd like to play that you
liked playing off of with oscar
yeah the circumstance was confusing
because i'm like i just don't know what
it's like to be in this situation right
but it was uncomfortable and that
discomfort is what i brought to it
i definitely preferred stephen oscar was
so good at like moving forth between the
different the two that i just without
any intellectualization of it would feel
who he was and um
i was like naturally more nurturing with
steven and it was like fun and silly and
then with oscar i'm like what mood is
with mark i'm like what mood is he in
you know he's like more of an emo
like in his feelings kind of person but
oscar generally was very light
throughout the whole thing and i love to
be goofy and play in between takes and
he was just like always up for that
was there a scene that was just so
memorable for you to shoot in this i'm
curious because it feels like you've
garnered a lot of memory shooting this
is there one particular that maybe was
just super sentimental or really funny
i mean
in the second episode when we were
when we were filming and like i'm like
oh you do hieroglyphics and like he's
like pointing at something
i think i was like funeral rights and i
was trying to act like i knew what it
was but it was like he was he would
point specifically at the burial
icon which is like obviously at funeral
rites like he would just like mess with
me and so we'd always like i was like
stop i don't want to laugh like
i'm the kind of person and it happens on
raw me too like once i break
you just can't say
done i'm done and like everyone around
me starts just shaking and i'm like i'm
so sorry guys
like i'm gonna get fired
but there were a lot of those moments
where it was just kind of like cracking
and breaking and then there were
obviously like any any kind of fight was
so memorable for me because i was like i
never would have seen myself doing this
so now i love action
and
yeah i felt you killed it uh yeah it
sounds like it was a blast you killed it
in those action scenes what was it like
training for those the first week i was
so sore that i cried and i was just like
i don't know that they cast the right
person because i don't know if my body
can take this and then the week after
that i was fine
but the it was it was this french stunt
team and they were incredible i love
them and working with them every day was
so much fun
that
i woke up excited and i was like what a
dream to wake up every day excited to do
this and they just had different things
for me different obstacles like today
you're gonna learn how to use a gun and
today you're gonna learn to kick and
today this and
um
it was i was just a dream i i really
think a big part of what makes it great
is the people you work with and they
were all just like
pure good people that's so cool well
maybe you'll use those skills with dr
strange maybe because i heard that you
love dr strange i really love the
mystical side of things yeah what do you
love about that character and what would
you would you want your character to
interact with him i just love how we we
saw how and what he had to go through to
kind of learn and it wasn't easy for him
to get to where he was and then he's not
i mean none of them are without their
flaws but he
his i'm all about transformation and i
loved his transformation and just like
the the powers are are cool and they
feel
kind of infinite in this way where it
moves between dimensions and i'm always
interested in that
i think i'm losing it
we'll catch you on
you're bloody useless
stevie steven
[Music]
congratulations on moon night like what
what an incredible project to be a part
of i read that you said that when people
see this they're not going to recognize
that it's you directing this and so i
wanted to know why like what did you do
on moon night that was different from
your other work that stands apart from
all the other things you've done
ironically i'm going to tell you
something that feels the opposite but
it's not i actually feel like moon
knight is an extension of my small
independent films
because
at the core of it if you strip down all
the action and everything it's a story
it's an intimate story about someone
learning how to live with himself
and um
i sho i cannot make a film or or a show
about something that i can identify with
and i see myself like talking to you
being that nice guy that's my mask
that's my persona and there's something
else inside of me and all my journey
through life
trying to make those people the two per
the two sides of me being one is the
journey that every one of us go through
and that's why i identify with the moon
knight but um
i when i said people are not going to
recognize me because they're not going
to be able to believe that i actually
direct action in this way and direct
horror and direct comedy which i'm not
known for at all
and
but at the same time i was given the
chance to bring my movies this is why
it's darker this is why it tastes
differently and this is why people say
if you cut the marvel logo people are
gonna feel like this is a different show
and you're absolutely right and you
killed it and you were like the perfect
person for the job because it is that
right it's about stephen and mark
reconciling with their past present and
future um and us doing that too like
knowing we're not our past but having to
constantly like live with it and remind
ourselves of it it's it's incredible i
read that you made a 200 page pitch
for this what all goes into that what
was in there did a lot of it make it
into the show tell me about this 200
page moon night pitch
well i moved here uh three years ago me
and my wife starting from scratch we're
big in egypt but uh we always had this
dream that we can share our our stories
on on a bigger scale so we had couple of
projects but we never connected to
anything except maybe the moonlight is
the first pitch i've ever done in my
life wow the two of us so we for two
weeks after reading the the the
the
script
uh we put together this pitch and by the
way it's all pictures so you go through
it just like that it's not it's not like
a an essay that you have to spend days
reading it but it covered everything
um the locations
the editing the tone
the action how are we gonna shoot it the
music the music that you liked was in
the pitch two years ago
um and the score um
the locations in egypt how am i gonna
how are we gonna develop the the the
characters
and once we were done we told ourselves
i told sarah if we didn't get this job
something is wrong with the world
not because we covered everything it's
not about covering everything it's about
covering everything in a unique and a
unique voice when you know
that you're the best guy to tell that
story you're gonna get the job wow and
by the way that pitch became the bible
when we hired aaron and justin that's
what i handed them and that's why their
episodes feel like mine they're two
episodes and
today
that is the show
wow wow
and i have to thank marvel for letting
me
for hiring me for that uh uh
pitch and then letting me actualize that
pitch
right because it's one thing to pitch it
and then have people come in and scrap
things away but for that to be the bible
and the source
where do you keep it i want to meet
sarah i feel like she's the perfect
example behind every great man
i want to tell you an unbelievable woman
i always feel guilty be interviewed
without her
i know next next time um next time i
interview you we'll make sure sarah's
there we're making we're she's directing
her first film i'm pushing her as much
as i can she deserves it that's
incredible where do you guys keep this
pitch and what was the first thing you
did to celebrate when you got moon night
smart and very i wanted to tell that
story i was on the beach with her and
the kids
and we got that call it was a month
after the final pitch with kevin um
feige
and
my heart was pounding i'm getting a
marvel marvel is calling me grant is
calling me and he told me you got it
we started dancing my kids and on the
beach i'm not that kind of a crazy guy
so we were dancing and people didn't
know what we were doing and we were
embracing each other but just
imagining anyone in the u.s here getting
a job like this would dance but just
imagining someone from a small town in
egypt
learning his english from american
movies
this is this is huge and
feeling the burden of or the weight and
the responsibility and the honor of
being the first egyptian to tell our
stories to the world uh it's it's i'm
proud and honored and lucky
and guess what it's only the beginning
which is probably the best part of all
this super i love that visual of you
guys dancing um you directed the first
episode and the first episode really
sets the tone for the entire series so
what elements were really important for
you to be in that first episode uh
because it was setting the tone
the first time i talked with oscar oscar
isaac um
he
saw my two movies uh clash and amira and
he was reluctant because he came from
big just came out from big movies uh
dune and uh star wars and x-men and he
just wanted to make intimate films and
he told muhammad what the hell are you
doing here
i told him
oscar
i don't think making small movies is is
just for
making intimate stories is just for uh
small movies you can do intimate stories
uh in in big budget movies and that's
when we both
started
i pitched him how i see the show and uh
we started working on making this a
character's study so it was very
important for me to know
who steven is to know him as a real
person my favorite scene
and it's a scene that me and sarah wrote
and we fought for it is the diner scene
that's the moment that you love steven
that's the moment that you realize okay
the id
every time i hear about someone who has
the id i think okay he has those
blackouts or whatever and then he goes
back to life but no
he
stephen can have a date he can have a
normal life everything is hard in his
life
that steak moment
is is the moment that really it's my
favorite scene in episode one
it is so good and it's because it's so
human and you're right like we can have
these intimate incredible stories told
like through these big epic scope ways
and and you're so such a master at that
which is why you know you were on this
project they're my one of my that is one
of my favorite scenes another one of my
favorite scenes is the truck backwards
scene
what was it like shooting that for oscar
and stephen and i have a random question
for you have you seen licorice pizza not
yet okay there was a scene where alana
hyam is driving a truck backward
and i was wondering if you had seen that
no no but tell me about shooting that
well shooting that was an interesting
thing because i'm usually like any scene
is shot like in a day or half a day or
like hours and that seemed like took
like a week more than a week between
shooting in on location in slovenia
um and then shooting on
on stage it was such an interesting uh
uh scene it was one of the first times
that i learned to use uh previous i'm
one of the characters i'm one of the
directors who need the location to
understand how i'm gonna shoot it in
three minutes after seeing the location
and the actors doing it once i know how
to shoot it but you can't do that with
big action sequences so i had to
discover that
in the previous
and that scene was created and i knew
that it's going to be different well in
a show you're not competing with big
budget the biggest action sequences so
we created our own unique thing the idea
of a blink
the idea that this
action sequence is not
the fastest and the furious it has to
have a different tone and the funny have
you heard the song on the um
sarah picked the best song over it
honestly except i i'll give everyone
their credit that's my editor
sarah picked all the all the other songs
in the show every single one of them
except that one my great cedric the the
great editor
a perfect song and it just like tells
you don't take us seriously and don't
don't take the narrator seriously so
i love that uh scene so much and um uh
it's it's one of the my favorite scenes
because again it's a small action
sequence but it's not it's it's unique
and the blinks
i don't think anyone saw something like
that the idea of
i get by the way when i see a movie and
i'm not that attached to the characters
if it's an action movie
sometimes i go to the bathroom and come
back in the middle of the action
sequences because who cares but in in in
what we really the fresh thing every
time i told my team the fresh thing
about our see our action sequences were
the black house
you never saw that you're on or on your
seat because you don't know if this
action sequencer is going to continue or
i'm going to find myself in a different
place did something weird
that's partially why i love
steven because we
seeing the whole show through stephen
and mark
getting the feeling of someone who has
the id is is something very important
i can't tell the difference
between
[Music]
hope you find it
thanks
hello hi justin and aaron how are you
guys long day huh
that's fine good how are you
i'm swell actually i'm spectacular it's
beautiful outside i get to talk to you
guys about this like
revolutionary i want to use um show that
blends so many genres so flawlessly and
effortlessly uh thanks in part to you
guys and i know um you know you're used
to making sci-fi horror films so i was
wondering what elements of um you know
justin and aaron do you think people are
going to find in moon night
i mean it was pretty mind-blowing to us
when we first saw the scripts to the
episodes that we did and and how similar
they were in tone to our work as feature
film directors um
it's fun you know when we're making
something that ultimately gets
categorized as
as again like you said sci-fi horror
we wear that with a badge of honor but
we also will fully acknowledge that like
oh the rhythm of the humor comes from
almost famous by cameron crowe it's not
you know like we've always been bouncing
into other genres wherever it felt
appropriate to the extent
that um outside of a marketing label our
movies probably shouldn't even have a
genre placed on them technically we're
breaking so many rules of the genre
usually um and there was something about
tackling a character that
if we didn't do that
you felt like the character from the
comic book was gonna confront you on it
like
they would literally be offended at what
you've done if you stayed within the
confines of one particular genre are you
guys seeing moon knight in your in your
nightmares is conscious showing up well
they're not nightmares they're lovely
they're lovely
wow that was like poor wording on my
part absolutely
um speaking of conscious though like
what a cool character
i wanted to talk to you guys about him
and sort of what did you envision for
him in his seemingly strange
relationship with mark
yeah well i think what we really
uh tried to do with kanchu
after going to the comics and trying to
establish exactly what he is to moon
knight and we're gonna say moon knight
is all of the personalities that are
being represented um
conscious we wanted to actually find
just a real life allegory for that sort
of a relationship for example like we
find there to be a fraternal
relationship between like mark and
stephen konshu
has you know in some ways a paternal
relationship but also he's abusive and
he's he's mean and petty and small
and uh and so we wanted to you know
try to think about
you know experiences that we've all had
in our own lives and this wasn't just
the two of us this was all of the
collaborators on it would look into our
own lives and see if there was somebody
that could kind of be a stand-in for
consu
so that he would not just be kind of a
one-note joke or you know just an
oppressed oppressive top-down figure but
he's actually strangely got his own
humanity you feel bad for him at certain
points which is weird to feel for you
know
cgi dead bird you know
i love how weird this show is and it
works like i love how weird it is and
how it works it's so good um
one of the scene there's a lot of scenes
of obviously mark and steven talking to
each other and i was curious to ask the
both of you what it was like directing
oscar during those scenes and what that
was like and what conversations you guys
were having on set
you know
something we always say about oscar is
not only is he
one of our generation's best actors but
he's also one of our greatest
collaborators and he's going to show up
with everything figured out he's a
perfectionist he is going to go between
playing these different characters with
a fluidity that is awe-inspiring and he
does it in such a way that's always just
so kind and and so collaborative and
and always taking feedback so gracefully
um from us and uh and you know we we
take pride in saying that you know we
helped shape this in some way but almost
feels weird saying it because so much of
it is just oscar yeah being a
spectacular performer it's it's really
great honestly just to watch a genius at
the top of their game and even on like
day 75 you know you're all tired you're
in it you barely even know what day it
is you know but this guy doesn't blink
you know and so every single time that
you work with him it's like eating the
best meal of your life it's these
culinary delights and you can just kind
of like keep on
watching and learning all day every day
and uh and it's it's as exciting as you
might imagine being able to work with
oscar and ethan and may you guys got me
on the edge of my seat where i just like
wish i could be there when when stephen
and mark are talking to each other how
did you guys shoot those scenes with
someone
sort of off to the corner like reading
the other characters lines
you know oftentimes oscar had it so
dialed in that he could just literally
go between the different characters so
if we just you know swung the camera
over to a reflection he could he could
just switch like that no problem yet
from day one never had a problem with it
and you know he's just that guy and then
um
and then uh on days where
you know he needed someone to act
against his double uh his brother mikey
he was a great actor in his own right
and they uh
and was really fun just to have on set
and get to know those guys and get to
know their family
wow that's cool what was it like
directing mikey and oscar then together
oh you know what's funny though i mean
they're brothers
we're not gonna get in between that they
they worked with each other we we
directed oscar um there was there were
tiny little times where he'd say all
right mikey give him a little more heat
you know or whatever but just just you
know for the most part honestly that was
their relationship and uh it was
actually really fun to listen in on the
intercom as they were working working
out their little bits because what it
was was it was oscar working out how he
was going to have to then give it later
you know
um and that was that was really
by the way surreal to watch you know
somebody kind of trying to figure out
how they're going to be in a few hours
it sounds like an outer body experience
sort of like watching him do his thing
it's so cool you guys um got to direct
him and you do have a lot of influence
in this by the way um in later episodes
there seems to be like a nod to indiana
jones and there's like this awesome
sense of adventure did you guys draw
inspiration
from that franchise
yeah you know is interesting is that um
we'd be lying if we didn't say everyone
wanted to do an indiana jones-esque
adventure from the very beginning
because you know you look at those
movies and it's like oh what are they
one second they're hilarious the next
second there's these visceral thrills of
being an adventurer and the next second
you can be terrified by fight by
something gives kids nightmares for
generations
well they're not nightmares yeah
okay
i know what it's funny though but with
aaron and i specifically it's like oh
once we get that we understand what the
general vibe is we'll tend to very
intentionally not
expose ourselves too much to that that
material that you're drawing from so
that you hopefully end up with something
that's
that's different and you don't
unconsciously um
uh
pay too much homage yeah yeah i mean if
we're if we're making moon knight which
is this character that has no strings
attached to him and no no shackles on
them you can do anything you want to it
would be weird to then go and retread
familiar ground you know it's kind of
against the whole idea
right yeah no that makes sense um i also
wanted to ask you guys about what it was
like directing oscar and ethan hawk
together
because those scenes are so um absorbing
i feel like when the both of them are on
screen so what was that like
i mean with with ethan um in my case i
literally wouldn't be a filmmaker
without ethan hawk because i i saw the i
saw before sunrise and a couple other
movies that he's done with richard link
later at my like formative filmmaking
years and i was like that's what i want
to do with my life i want to make stuff
like that so he was i was me becoming a
filmmaker was literally the result of
seeing his past work but then beyond all
of that he's also
he's a he's a
he's written some beautiful novels uh
his last one in particular is just so
wonderful and good we're on set read
that in a single day it was so good yeah
one of our most accomplished just
general filmmakers of our generation if
you you watch blaze that he wrote and
directed that movie is one of the
greatest indie films of the last decade
um
he's just a great all-around filmmaker
all-around artist and to get to work
with him in this capacity and to see how
his mind works to see how
he brings humanity into especially a
villain or something you traditionally
call a villain you learn so much from
him seeing him go through that process
and he's so open to you collaborating
with him and to see him and oscar on
screen at the same time
there's a few of those scenes we did
that were probably our best experiences
on this
on this show um
yeah he's a uh he's such a he's such a
good human being
that i remember when we were first going
to go meet him we were we're both pretty
intimidated i i know my own emotions i
was i was just like man i don't want i
don't want him to decide i'm an idiot
you know i just really want ethan to
and he is just an incredibly open and
vulnerable guy while also somehow being
a guru level
genius
um that it feels like he's actually
listening to and implementing your ideas
immediately as soon as we met um and and
and it's kind of a funny thing where
it's like who am i to give ethan hawk
direction
and yet
um he he absorbs it you know he's he's a
sponge he's a he's a child with his eyes
wide open at the same time as being one
of the most accomplished actors of our
time
[Music]
yeah oh my god you're alive what's wrong
with you mark
why did you call me mark
i um feel so lucky to talk to you about
what a special series you know to be
added to marvel and i read that you
specifically said that you didn't want
moon knight or this show to be connected
to any other stories or characters in
the mcu and i was wondering why is that
well i mean this this story and this
character definitely is in the mcu um
and but
there's not a lot of contact points that
we were beholden to to tell moon
knight's story and i do think once once
you start diving into the moon knight
comics you know this is a character that
got launched in 1975 in werewolf by
night and then kind of bounced around in
various marvel ips for five years and
finally
his own comic was launched in 1980. and
so when you look at the years and not
just the years the decades of
storytelling and the rich storytelling
the complex storytelling we realized we
did not need any particular connectivity
in other in the other narratives that
the mcu was flowing in and out of this
story was moon knight's story you know
as a standalone and that's definitely
the way we approached it was never a
conscious decision it was just like
what's the best story that emerges from
the pages of the comic that can be
transferred to the screen and that's
really where this mcu offering emerged
from is a character story um mark
specter his complex personality disorder
um he's obviously dealing with
dissociative identity disorder and just
what's that best story that we can tell
and how does that eventually merge into
the marvel cinematic universe
i i love where where that mindset is too
like let's just tell the best story
because we live in a world now right
where everything is so connected um so
it was so fun diving into this world of
course i've only seen a couple episodes
but it is spectacular now i want to ask
you on the other side of the coin i'm a
little bit of a hypocrite now that you
have established moon knight's world do
you you know would you want to see him
interact with other characters like what
would a season two look like well you
know as you know from seeing some of the
episodes that you had as you have
tonally we're painting on a lot of
different canvases here we have a
globetrotting action adventure we have a
very intense character study we have the
humor that you get with the marvel
cinematic universe also you know on the
moon night pages things go bump in the
night there's certain spookier aspects
of moon knight comic that does
transition onto the screen so i think
you have so many different aspects
tonally of moon knight where this
character merges into the mcu is
anybody's guess i mean it's obviously as
you can imagine kevin feige's ultimate
decision but because this is such a rich
tapestry that was woven together for
this series i think where he goes in the
future he could land anywhere wow what a
line rich tapestry i love that and you
guys blend these genres so seamlessly
because it all works and it and watching
it you're like how does this all work uh
you mentioned kevin grant
what was it like meeting with you know
oz what was his vision for this show and
uh tell me about your conversations with
kevin about moonlight well i mean you
know kevin and i go back to 2000 2001
2002 spider-man 1. so that's that's how
long kevin and i go back but then
obviously kevin has gone on to launch
um this amazing marvel cinematic
universe but it was working closely with
kevin within the confines of marvel
studios now that truly amazed me and
invigorated me daily i remember a
conversation that we had very early on
the development process we bumped into
each other in the kitchen and he said
how's it going and you know jeremy
slater and the writers team we've been
going for a while then and we've made a
lot of progress but we hadn't cracked it
per se yet and kevin said you know what
let me tell you a story about when i was
a kid i was in brooklyn and my parents
put me on a train into manhattan and i
remember standing in line vividly a line
that was wrapped around the block to get
into the egyptian art exhibit that was
traveling through the country and he
said i remember the excitement that i
had both waiting in line and then also
seeing these great um you know these
great paintings and all this art and
architecture that continues to
invigorate and mesmerize us today he
said if we can capture the feeling i had
being a kid on that day and if we can
infuse that feeling into this show we've
got a series and so from that day on we
really took his direction
and made this much more of an egyptology
egyptology-centric
indiana jones style globetrotting action
adventure and that's what makes the show
that the audience is going to see on
march 30th that's pure kevin feige
that's jeremy slater our head rider in
our hardworking writers room and then
obviously our great directors muhammad
diab uh and vincent and morehead and
then
rounding out obviously is our amazing
cast of ethan oscar and may
i feel like they should all just walk
out right now
because that anecdote is so cool in the
kitchen i have so many questions my
first is like what hat was kevin wearing
did he have a moon night merch this
early on like that's where my mind went
um i know you've made it at marvel when
you show up at a meeting and kevin's
wearing the moon night camp it's like ah
yes yes i'm here i have been we've got a
show yeah i'm so happy for you i think
you did you did evoke that feeling and
what a cool like tone and direction to
get it it is very night at the museum
but like we said earlier there's so many
different genres the show is very deep
right um
i i read that you said that it's also
about moon knight reconciling with
this show is really about reconciling
with your past present and future yes
and so i was wondering how you think the
different personas like steven and mark
challenge each other to do that
well i think you know i don't speak for
all of us but i think we all have part
of our past and presence that we have to
atone for and that's really what we as
an audience
watch in real time with stephen grant
and mark spector as they're trying to
work out the aspects of their
personalities in their um and their
particular universe you know
who am i in this universe where am i
going from here what's my future look
like how do i atone for my past sins how
do i deal with this new dynamic that i'm
possibly a superhero and that i'm
possibly obviously also an avatar of
this crazy egyptian god consciou
and so really it's just i think that's
what makes moon knight series special it
always keeps the audience guessing as to
where this character or these characters
is going to go next um and that's where
i think the amazing
aspect of bringing oscar isaac to the
table and an actor absolutely working at
the top of his craft because this is a
very difficult character to embody
characters to embody i should say
properly um and he does it seamlessly
and that was amazing
it it really is unbelievable to to see
like literally seconds apart that the
range of emotions that is that he like
brings to all these characters like you
were saying um and even appearance wise
is exciting for marvel fans let's talk
about like the design of moon knight and
the costumes and konchu and like what
all went into that and what
conversations are you guys having
crafting this because this is the first
time a live action moon night has been
brought to life
absolutely i mean you know first of all
we started in the pages you know where
it always starts and there's been some
amazing moon knight and mr knight
designs drawn over the years and that
was really our foundation our costume
designer megan was absolutely amazing
with coming up with different concepts
and you know ryan and the incredible
concept team at marvel turning out
different options and opportunities that
we had to explore with this character
who's come whose costume has changed
over the years but it was really you
know using that north star that's the
great line in the comic you know i wear
white because i want the bad guys to see
me coming so we always knew that we had
a character that was going to have a
white costume and then what we could
play with within that and you know it's
one thing you know oscar a big fan of
the ip a big fan of moon knight and when
he came aboard he just kept on
challenging us you know how can we make
this different how can we make this
unique hey i was i was doing my research
last night i saw this thing how can we
infuse the costume with this aspect that
i saw on the page so it was really just
dealing with a bunch of different
artists artists and craftsmen and women
that really came together to bring this
amazing costume and costumes to the to
the screen was there a specific piece of
artwork that that like sticks out to you
that was like a big point of inspo or
comic specifically it was obviously a
variety and i i think to the viewer
who's also the comic book fan when you
look at the costume that we present on
screen i think you're gonna see a little
bit of a blend of the last you know from
1975 on um different aspects of those
those um
different aspects of that costume
infused into what we're bringing to the
screen and i think they're gonna like it
it's it's a very cool costume obviously
this show tackles mental health issues
thank you for sharing all that about the
costume did you guys have a professional
on hand
um to sort of consult on those things
yeah for moon knight we worked with a
variety of consultants an egyptologist
but another one of the consultants that
we worked with was a mental health
professional
dr puri
and as we were building this character
out you know the writer's room was open
to dr puri and vice versa he read all of
our scripts and obviously we're dealing
with a unique situation we're dealing
with a superhero so we're dealing with
that canvas um we're also dealing with a
fictional character
that has a supernatural bent to it but
you know what we strove for from day one
as you can imagine was being respectful
um and reverential to the mental health
issue that our character is dealing with
and we think through a variety of
consultants help we were able to present
a fictionalized version of that that the
audience will start seeing soon and
start loving soon thank you so much for
talking to me i uh am obsessed with the
music on this show i like wanna know all
about the inside i don't know if you
like two seconds to just tell me a
little bit of it because the music
selections were just fire well you know
the music is is bananas cool i mean it's
awesome
it's it's on my it's believe me it's on
my um it's on my phone and it plays
non-stop but what i do have to really
call out you know when muhammad diab the
great egyptian filmmaker came aboard
what we didn't know right away but
became apparent very quickly is how many
people want to work with this director
and so if you do look at our credits
hashem is our composer he's an egyptian
composer that would not have come to the
table through any other avenues except
with muhammad deaf saying this guy is
dope he's at the top of his game in
egypt we got to give him a listen we did
he blew us away same thing with one of
the editors um ahmed he edited episodes
three and four um he's a gentleman and
an editor who has worked with muhammad
in the past probably wouldn't have been
on our radar any other way unless we
strove for authenticity at all aspects
it is another one of the things that
when you bring muhammad diab to this
table
you're going to bring a story that
people haven't seen before told by
people you probably haven't seen before
either so that's that was exciting
you